el sistema de salud en ucrania está
colapsado y los hospitales quedan en
medio del asedio sin suministro de
organización médicos del mundo trabaja
para llevarlos hasta donde más se
necesitan en medio de la guerra crearon
un corredor logístico entre rumanía y
ucrania para poder importar medicamentos
una de las principales veces necesidades
que tiene a día de hoy la población out
and ya no es todo el suministro de
bienes básicos para para poder continuar
lo que es la vida normal dentro de estos
bienes básicos está todo el tema de las
medicinas porque
en muchos hospitales se encuentran sin
medicinas y no pueden continuar la
atención médica pero no solo las
medicinas de escasean en las zonas
controladas de donges está las mujeres
responden a la falta de sangre para
tratar a los heridos mientras siguen
llegando a las puertas de los hospitales
hay una acción militar en marcha espero
que mi sangre ayude a salvar la vida de
alguien con más de 1000 civiles muertos
tras un mes de guerra según datos de la
onu otro escenario se vive en kiev en
este crematorio los restos de quienes
han muerto por la guerra se acumulan
el 15 de marzo mi hija me llamo a la
madrugada y me dijo que un misil había
impactado en su edificio el edificio se
incendió le dijimos que se vistiera que
tomara su pasaporte y saliera corriendo
volvió a llamar diciendo que la puerta
no se abría debido al toque de queda no
pudimos llegar hasta ella
en el crematorio se apilan las urnas de
las víctimas de la invasión rusa y
algunos restos estarán allí por largo
tiempo ya que muchos de los familiares
de los fallecidos huyeron de kiev en
busca de seguridad